the turkish lira continues to plunge as
inflation is soaring in turkey the
annual inflation rate in turkey has
soared to a 20-year high of nearly 50
percent the turkish lira lost 44 of its
value in 2021 and consumer prices have
spiked 11 in january compared to the
previous month turkey central bank has
continued to cut interest rates by 500
basis points since september we're now
at 14
and real rates they've dropped all the
way down to 35 percent part of this is
driven by president erdogan's ability to
try to get re-elected as the president
of turkey coming up here in 2023 he has
continued to try to spurn growth and
wants the central bank within turkey to
cut interest rates even lower but what
we've seen is inflation rate continues
to get crazy and it's going higher and
higher this has led citizens to continue
to adopt bitcoin at a rapid pace what
we've seen is they are opting for sound
money they want to get out of the
turkish lira and the president is not
okay with that we have a quote here
where president erdogan is saying we
don't want people to adopt bitcoin we
have absolutely no intention of
embracing cryptocurrencies on the
contrary we have a separate war a
separate fight against them we would
never lend support to cryptocurrencies
because we will move forward with our
own currency that has its own identity
but what we've seen is the citizens
don't care there's at least 14 million
people out of turkey's population of 84
million that hold cryptocurrencies today
according to bhaktas harabu which allows
turks to use their bank accounts to buy
and sell crypto in the turkish lira has
seen its user base grow from around 1.5
million at the open of 2021 to nearly 5
million by year's end and john i'm
curious your opinion on this but mine is
like
we've seen this all over the world right
when countries have instability within
their own currency inflation rates are
crazy high and they don't have the
ability to save they opt for a better
technology which is bitcoin we've seen
this in other countries outside of
turkey and now that turkey is
experiencing insane inflation rates it
hasn't been below 10
for a long period of time and now it's
at 50 year-over-year they're literally
losing their purchasing power overnight
and what they're opting to do is for
sound money and they're saying hey even
if you guys don't support bitcoin it
doesn't matter right usage is going up
when you ban something in a country
where they know you're not doing
something in their best interest they're
going to go and adopt that technology
and i think that's exactly what we've
seen what do you think i think the
citizens of turkey can really benefit
from the use of bitcoin and they're
showing that with their free market and
moving their own money into bitcoin and
other cryptocurrencies like 50 losing 50
of value in a currency within one year
is insane 12
in just one or 11 in just one month is
not good for the citizens so they're
opting and they're looking for other
ways that they can use to save their
money and store that and use as a store
of value and that's what bitcoin and
other cryptocurrencies are providing for
them right now um look
worst thing you can do is hold on to a
mistake for a long time and eventually
you have to let your own currency go i
don't think that erdogan's going to do
that any time soon as he tries to
rebuild it but look we'll see what
happens in the next year or two well
it's very clear that the president and
the government there is not on their
side right here in the united states we
have inflation that's the seven percent
people are bugging out they don't even
believe that data and they're saying hey
uh the fed is saying we need to hike
interest rates immediately to kind of
curtail this inflation get it under
control in turkey interest rates are uh
inflation is at a 50 is that a 20-year
high it's at 50
and what we've seen is now they're
continuing to lower rates because
they're trying to spur and growth ahead
of an election cycle and the president
wants to get reelected within the polls
and show that they have everything under
control that is completely the wrong
approach the citizens know that it's not
in their best interest and what they've
done is they've shown and they and
they've moved with their wallets right
and they've started to adopt bitcoin and
other things and saying hey we don't
believe in the approach that you guys
are taking of this we want to uh kind of
have sound money we want to have
programmatic money we want to know
exactly what the inflation rate is going
to be we're going to opt out of your
system of your currency and go to a
superior system and a superior savings
technology and i think that's exactly
what we've seen in turkey and what we'll
continue to see around the world when
governments mess around raise inflation
or inflation expectations get higher and
higher and then citizens get screwed
they're going to continue to adopt
bitcoin and other digital assets and opt
for better savings technology